avec plaisir ne refuse jamais un combat
carapuce tiède est génial
il s'est enfin réveillé
damon le plus fort de tous
oui auto voilà ton ans et plus disent
que vous m'avez humble avis je contre
attaque
j'avais repéré tous les droits car vous
n'êtes que j'aimerais ça plein d'avenir
le plus grand dresseur de pokémon au
monde aux habitudes
grands dresseurs du monde ils nous
attendent de l'autre côté de la mer il
voit seulement on avait juste
ouais
c'est nous qui t'avons donner la vie et
pour y arriver nous avons utilisé un
fragment du pokémon le plus rare
si ces êtres faits de lait cru elle
était toujours amené à diriger la
planète
celle ci serait condamnée à brève
échéance lequel d'entre vous veut
m'affronter le premier je ne sais pas
vous mais moi j'aime pas ça mais bon si
tu y tiens
je vois que tu es tout de même capable
de te battre
mais quoi
oui mais quoi
[Musique]